(Alle) # Schwiizer Nati,
Schwiizer Nati - ole, ole!
6:0 gegen Island.
Geglückter Neustart
der Schweizer Nationalmannschaft.
Nach den Turbulenzen
an der WM in Russland,
wollen Spieler und Funktionäre
wieder zur Tagesordnung übergehen.
Die Landung des Doppeladlers in
den Schweizer Stuben: Schwamm drüber!
Falls sich irgendwelche Leute in
der Schweiz angegriffen fühlten ...
Vielleicht schaute jemand in den
Bergen das Spiel und es störte ihn.
Dann würde ich mich
sicher entschuldigen.
Darf man die Schweizer
als Bergler bezeichnen?
Wer ist ein richtiger Schweizer?
Und wie viele Heimaten darf
ein Mensch in seinem Herzen tragen?
Davon handelt dieser Film.
* Schleppende, fanfarenartige Musik *
Noch zusammenlegen. Richi?
Ja?
Du hast kein Weisses, oder?
- Nein.
Schade.
Vor dem Ehepaaar Voser aus Igis
liegt eine aufregende Fussballwoche:
Rot tragen wir in der Schweiz.
Das Weisse
tragen wir bei Auswärtsspielen.
Die Nati trägt auswärts
auch das weisse Tenü.
Hast du die Tickets?
- In der Tasche.
Gut. - Ja, alles gut.
- Handy? Portemonnaie?
Heute spielt die Schweiz
in St. Gallen gegen Island.
Und morgen schon fliegen die Vosers
mit der Nati nach England.
Richi und Ruth
halten ihrer Nati eisern die Treue.
Politik gehört
einfach nicht in den Fussball.
Die Nati hat sicher gelitten.
Wir spüren das auch im Umkreis:
"Was? Du gehst noch zuschauen?"
Ich glaube,
an das nächste Spiel nach Leicester
kommen nicht mehr all zu viele mit,
so wie es früher
eigentlich der Fall war.
Aber, ähm ...
Es liegt an der Mannschaft,
dass sie das wieder gutmacht.
Dass sie mit guter Leistung
und gutem Fussball zeigt,
dass sie
eine gute Schweizer Nati ist,
die unser Land mit guten Leistungen
auf dem Feld vertritt.
Im St. Galler Kybunpark
brutzeln schon die OLMA-Bratwürste.
Am Grill steht Vincenc Lazraj,
Schweizer mit albanischen Wurzeln.
Eine Dose und zweimal Bratwurst?
Das macht 20.50 Fr.
20 Fr. passen.
Es ist gut so.
Du kommst ja nächstes Mal wieder.
- Ja, ja.
Lazraj ist Coach des albanischen
Drittliga-Fussballvereins FC Besa.
Als Fünfjähriger
ist er in die Schweiz gekommen.
Sie tragen das Schweizer Kreuz
auf der Brust.
Genau.
Auch in der Brust?
- Ja, auf jeden Fall!
Ich habe auch einen Schweizer Pass.
Die grösste Zeit meines Lebens
habe ich hier verbracht.
In meinem Kollegenkreis
sind sehr viele Schweizer dabei.
Mein Kollegenkreis
ist international.
Auf jeden Fall bin ich ...
Ich merke selbst,
dass ich Schweizer Attitüden habe.
Was ist an Ihnen typisch albanisch?
- Typisch albanisch?
Dass ich ...
... ähm ...
Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Bin ich so sehr Schweizer,
dass mir das Albanische fehlt? Nein.
Bei mir ist es so, dass ich
immer etwas emotional werde.
Ich bin nahe am Wasser gebaut
oder emotional ...
Oder wenn ich im Stress bin,
gebe ich vielleicht etwas Gas.
Da fehlt mir etwas
die Ruhe des Schweizers.
Aber es ist gut - der Mix ist gut.
(Ruth) Team Switzerland.
Xhaka.
Seferovic.
Shaqiri kommt am Schluss.
- Ja.
* Ruth und Richi lachen. *
Shaqiri kommt am Schluss
und zwinkert dann immer so.
Richi Voser ist Fussballer
mit Leib und Seele.
Beim FC Bonaduz,
wo Voser für die Veteranen kickt,
hat man sich über
die Doppeladler-Querelen geärgert.
Wir sind Bergler.
Es ist eine Aussage,
die uns ein wenig getroffen hat,
dass Shaqiri
von diesen Berglern gesprochen hat.
Damit meint er eigentlich,
wir seien hinter dem Mond
und hätten keine Ahnung
von Fussball. Das ist nicht so.
Wir besuchen die Spiele auch immer
und haben eine Ahnung von Fussball.
Diese Aussage nehme ich ihm
etwas übel - ein wenig.
Müssen die, die auf dem Platz stehen,
Schweizer sein?
Es ist nicht mehr relevant.
Es ist die Situation,
die wir in der Schweiz haben.
Es ist so, dass wir
relativ viele Migranten haben
oder Leute aus anderen Nationen.
Damit müssen wir leben.
Die Situation ist einfach so.
Es gibt nicht nur Eidgenossen,
sondern auch Schweizer.
Ich bin stolz auf das, was ich bin.
Ich verleugne
meine Nationalität nicht.
Es ist gut so, wie es ist.
Wir sind Albaner,
wir sind hier aufgewachsen.
Ja, hey, schau!
Die Sprache spreche ich fliessend.
Wir haben auch etwas von hier.
Schweizer? Albaner? Egal.
Heute gilt: alle gegen Island!
* Hopp-Schwiiz-Rufe *
* Jubel *
(Speaker) Neuer Spielstand:
Schweiz ...
- (Alle) 1.
Island ...
- (Alle) 0.
# Ole, ole, ole!
# Schwiizer Nati!
Ich bin stolz,
dass das 2:0 gefallen ist,
egal, wer das Tor geschossen hat.
Es steht 2:0 für die Schweiz.
Das ist ein super Resultat.
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Oh!
- Jetzt!
Ja!
- Yeah! - Juhu!
Es steht 4:0.
Das Spiel ist super,
also taktisch gesehen.
Yeah!
Ist der Neustart geglückt?
- Ja, es ist super.
Man hat ein paar
taktische Änderungen gesehen.
Und ...
Es ist wirklich
zusammen mit dem Speed ...
Es gibt mehr Speed
und mehr Spielfreude.
Tags darauf am Flughafen Zürich.
Ruth und Richi Voser
reisen mit der Schweizer Nati
zum Testspiel nach England.
Wohin fliegen wir? Nach London?
- Nein, nein, nein.
Nach ... Ach.
Sag mir, wohin fliegen wir?
Birmingham.
- Ja, genau. - D 43.
D 43, ja.
(Alle) Zum Wohl!
Hopp Schwiiz!
Auf ein paar schöne Tore,
so wie gestern.
(Mann) Vielleicht haben sie
schon alles verschossen.
(Richi) Es sind meistens
dieselben Leute.
Man sieht sich während dem Jahr
nicht, dafür an den Spielen.
Sind das nun die Hardcore-Fans?
Ja, es ist zumindest
eine der Kerngruppen. Ja, ja.
Die Besten!
Jene, die eigentlich immer
dabei sind, mehr oder weniger.
Ihre Ferien gleichen die Vosers
mit dem Spielplan der Nati ab.
Was erhoffen Sie sich
für die nächste Auslosung?
Länder, die wir noch nicht kennen.
Ja.
* Stimmengewirr *
Shaqiri kennt uns sicher.
Das hat er auch gestern gezeigt,
als er aus dem Bus gestiegen ist.
* Dynamische Musik *
Sie kriegen besseres Essen als wir.
(Mann) Liebe Fussballfans,
liebe Nationalmannschaft,
hier spricht Ihr erster Offizier
mit Informationen aus dem Cockpit.
Wir befinden uns über England,
haben den Sinkflug eingeleitet.
D.h. für uns,
dass wir die Landung in Birmingham
bereits in etwa 15-20 Min. erwarten.
Bei der Gepäckausgabe in Birmingham
warten Ruth und Richi Voser
und die anderen Fans
vergeblich auf die Schweizer Spieler.
Vermutlich werden sie
vor den Journalisten abgeschirmt.
Die Journalisten sind auch hier.
Die Journalisten warten auch,
und ein paar Fans sind auch hier.
Ich weiss nicht, was das
für eine Taktik ist. Keine Ahnung.
Bisher war es immer so,
dass sie auf das Gepäck gewartet
haben, genauso wie wir auch.
So gibt es auch keine Kommunikation
mehr unter den Fans, was schade ist.
Es war ganz anders.
Unter Hitzfeld
sind die Gestalten hergekommen,
Hitzfeld war dabei
und stand nicht in irgendeiner Ecke.
So hat es auch noch
nach etwas ausgesehen.
Man konnte zu ihnen hin.
Man konnte mit ihnen kommunizieren.
Sie hatten Freude und wir auch.
Das ist jetzt nicht mehr so.
Von Birmingham aus
geht's im Bus nach Leicester.
Die Häuser sind z.T.
schon recht heruntergekommen.
Leicester
ist eine von 24 Destinationen,
die Richi Voser im Schlepptau
der Nati schon bereist hat.
Ohne Nati würden Sie
nicht hierherkommen?
Nein, sicher nicht.
Das ist ja auch ein Grund,
warum wir immer mitgehen.
Damit wir gewisse Städte anschauen,
die wir normalerweise
nicht besuchen würden.
Würden wir nur
wegen der Spiele herkommen,
wären wir vermutlich
nicht so oft dabei.
* Stimmengewirr *
They actually turn ...
... and they make noise.
* Lachen *
Da sind 20 ...
In einer Gruppe, in der auch Frauen
und nicht nur Männer sind,
ist es interessanter,
man schaut andere Dinge an.
Was schauen die Männer an,
wenn sie unter sich sind?
Bars!
Bars und Biergläser.
- Und Frauen.
Zur gleichen Zeit im altehrwürdigen
St. Galler Espenmoos.
In 5 Min. ist Anpfiff zum Spiel
FC Besa gegen den FC Gossau.
Es geht um viel. Der FC Besa
will den Aufstieg in die zweite Liga.
Haben Sie den Doppeladler
schon einmal gemacht? - Nein.
Hat sonst jemand nach einem Tor
den Doppelkopfadler gemacht?
Ein paar Mal.
- Ein paar Mal?
Es ist so?
Eh, wo ist ...
- Bereit machen!
Ich weiss, ich nerve, aber was haltet
ihr von der Doppeladler-Diskussion?
Das besprechen wir nach dem Match.
- Okay.
Wir müssen uns
auf den Match vorbereiten.
* Stimmengewirr *
Alle in den Kreis!
Ich will sehen, dass wir ihnen
zeigen, dass wir hier der Chef sind,
dass wir hier zu Hause sind,
dass wir
die ersten Zweikämpfe gewinnen,
dass wir den zweiten
und den ersten Ball haben!
Schaffen wir das,
dann nehmen sie keinen Punkt mit.
Also, Jungs, ich wünsche euch
ein gutes Spiel! Alles Gute!
* Anfeuerungsschrei *
* Anpfiff *
Allez! Kommt!
Mentor! Bleiben, Mentor!
Zweiter Ball, zweiter Ball, Sheval!
Sheval, zweiter Ball!
Scheisse!
Hey, Jungs! Sind wir wach?
Sind wir langsam wach?
Schläft ihr?
Da ist sie,
die sprichwörtliche Heissblütigkeit.
In der Vergangenheit handelte sich
der Verein damit schon Probleme ein.
Und der Doppeladler?
Für mich ist der Doppeladler
kein Thema. Nein!
Jeder jubelt auf seine Weise.
Nehmen wir die Afrikaner
als Beispiel.
Sie tanzen.
Oder wie die Chinesen
oder sonst wer ...
Der Doppeladler ist einfach
das Symbol unserer Nation.
* Lautes Schreien *
Scheisse! Entschuldigung!
Er hätte beinahe ...
Der Verband
verlangte eine Entschuldigung.
hätte seine Jungs schützen müssen.
Sie spielen für den Verband.
Entschuldigen? Wozu?
Wozu?
Die Jungs sollen Fussball spielen.
Sie sollen alle Ausländer, die
in der Schweiz leben, stolz machen.
Wir sind stolz auf die
Schweizer Nati. Was will man mehr?
Hopp, hopp, hopp!
* Jubel *
Es ist genau das eingetreten,
was wir nicht wollten.
Wir haben zwei Tore erhalten,
die nicht nötig waren.
Wir sind defensiv
richtig schlecht dagestanden.
Da können wir den Ball halten.
Aber, Jungs! Qualität zeigen wir,
wenn wir den Ball
hier halten können.
Da kann es jeder,
da kann es jeder von uns.
Hin- und herspielen kann jeder.
Ich habe nicht das Gefühl,
dass ihr an eine bessere
zweite Halbzeit glaubt.
Wenn ihr nicht daran glaubt,
dann weiss ich auch nicht.
Ich bin davon überzeugt,
aber ich weiss nicht,
ob ihr selbst daran glaubt.
2:0 für den FC Gossau in der Pause.
Es bleiben 45 Min.,
um das Blatt zu wenden.
Von den Schuhläden
in die Pubs von Leicester.
Ein Zwischenhalt,
um auch anderen Fans der Reisegruppe
den Puls zu fühlen.
Zum Wohl!
(Mann) Viva!
- Viva.
Mir sind sie nicht mehr
so sympathisch wie früher,
aber trotzdem gehe ich zuschauen.
Warum nicht mehr so sympathisch?
Ich weiss es auch nicht.
Es ist ...
Die Typen, die dabei sind ...
Z.T. sind sie komisch.
Vielleicht ist das die heutige
Jugend, und ich sehe es anders.
Wer z.B.?
Oder ist die Frage zu heikel?
Es ist klar welche -
die Doppelbürger halt.
Der Doppeladler
ist hier nicht gut angekommen.
Das war politisch, von mir aus gese-
hen und hat nichts mit Sport zu tun.
Trägt er ein Schweizer Trikot,
muss er nicht solche Sachen machen.
Beim Public Viewing in Leicester
trifft man auch auf Fans,
die die zwei Herzen in der Brust
vieler Nati-Spieler verstehen.
Xhaka hat gesagt,
er habe nur einen Schweizer Pass,
er habe gar keinen anderen Pass.
Wie kann er es noch mehr zeigen?
Ich habe einen Namen,
eine Vergangenheit.
Ich fühle mich
für zwei Länder verantwortlich,
aber ich spiele für die Schweiz.
Wenn man sagt,
man spiele für die Schweizer Nati,
dann muss man es auch tun
und nicht nur sagen.
Es geht nicht nur um die Karriere.
Für einen solchen Spieler
ist es schwierig zu zeigen,
dass er nicht nur
für die Nationalmannschaft spielt,
sondern auch so fühlt.
Ich glaube,
es wäre für mich genauso schwierig,
wenn ich in einem anderen Land wäre,
total mitfühlen würde,
aber nicht weiss,
wie ich es zeigen soll.
Nach der 3:0-Niederlage am Sonntag -
Katzenjammer beim FC Besa.
Noch einmal zur Einstellung.
Ich habe den Match
von aussen angeschaut
und ich bin total gefrustet.
Es gab zu viele Situationen, in
welchen ihr nicht Gas gegeben habt,
bei den Sprints war es z.T. auch so.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ihr wisst, was
es vonseiten des Vorstands braucht,
um so ein Spiel zu organisieren,
um für euch an einem freien Sonntag
um 12 Uhr hierherzukommen
und bis um 17 oder 18 Uhr
für euch hier sein.
Nur für den FC Besa.
Ich appelliere an euch Spieler,
dass ihr euch dessen bewusst werdet,
dass ihr versteht,
was alles nötig ist
und was es heisst,
dieses Trikot zu tragen.
Seit der Gründung vor 26 Jahren
habe man beim FC Besa
viel für die Integration der Spieler
getan.
Ich denke, so ein Verein
öffnet andere Perspektiven,
was die Integration angeht.
Ein solcher Verein ist nötig.
Nur so kommt man
auch von aussen an Informationen,
wie das Leben im Alltag aussieht,
wie es mit anderen Nationalitäten
funktioniert.
Es geht ja nicht nur
um die Schweizer.
Es gibt in der Schweiz noch andere
Nationalitäten, die wichtig sind.
Eine Aktion unseres Marketingleiters
habe ich sehr schön gefunden.
Er hat alle Asylheime
in der Umgebung angefragt,
ob sie junge Spieler hätten,
die bei uns
Fussball spielen möchten.
Das ist doch ...
Ich finde das sehr vorbildlich.
Das hat nichts mit Albanern zu tun,
das hat mit Integration zu tun.
Die Türen sind
für alle Nationalitäten offen.
Auch für Schweizer?
- Ja, natürlich.
Wir haben einen Schweizer
in der ersten Mannschaft.
Auch bei den Junioren
spielen Schweizer.
Fühlen Sie sich nicht seltsam,
als Patrick ...
Nein, nein!
Ich bin mir das gewohnt.
Als ich zur Schule ging,
waren 70-80 % der Schüler Albaner
oder Kosovoalbaner.
Ich hatte es immer gut mit ihnen.
Ich habe kein Problem
und fühle mich wohl.
Integration geglückt!
Doch wie geht es weiter mit der Nati?
Im Stadion von Leicester
wird es eine ehrenvolle
1:0-Niederlage gegen England geben.
Die Schweizer Fans sind zufrieden.
Die Politik hat das Feld zugunsten
des Fussballs wieder geräumt.
* Schweizer Nationalhymne *
Auch im Stammlokal des FC Besa
in St. Gallen fachsimpelt man wieder
über Tore und Taktik statt
über Doppeladler und Doppelbürger.
Zeit, jemanden zu Wort
kommen zu lassen,
der sich selbst
als Halbaner bezeichnet.
Etrit Hasler ist der Sohn
einer Schweizerin und eines Albaners,
SP-Grossrat im Kanton St. Gallen,
Mitglied der Fachkommission Migration
und Integration:
Wie kann man behaupten,
dass es nicht politisch sein kann,
wenn Nationalmannschaften
gegeneinander spielen?
Es ist vom Konzept her schon so,
dass das politisch ist.
Politische Klischees
kommen wieder auf.
Es gibt
den wunderschönen Satz darüber,
dass Fussball Ersatz von Krieg ist,
einfach mit friedlichen Mittel.
Diesen Satz unterschreibe ich so.
Es wird eine durchaus
aggressive und fragwürdige Energie
in einen friedlichen Rahmen
kanalisiert.
Ich glaube, bei der National-
mannschaft ist es relativ banal.
Gewinnt sie ein paar Spiele,
dann ist das Land wieder versöhnt.